[Musique]
des boléros des danses bulgare tous les
styles tous les instruments étaient à
l'honneur samedi soir le conservatoire
de maurepas participé pour la première
fois à la nuit des conservatoires pas
richesse de la diffusion c'est faire
aimer la musique à tous les publics et
avoir une proximité et
créer vraiment une union avec le public
en fédérant un répertoire attractifs et
diversifiés
une première participation en mode grand
format de soirée et trois lieux
culturels différents de la commune
l'objectif est de montrer le dynamisme
et le tout la la créativité qui au sein
de présentant sainte de ce conservatoire
de mettre en valeur les élèves les
petits aussi bien que les grandes
équipes puissent se mettre en scène dans
des conditions qui sont quasi
professionnelle une quinzaine de rendez
vous les artistes en herbe ont pu
présenter le travail d'un trimestre
j'étais stressé parce que c'est ma
première fois mais c'était cool parce
que j'avais mes amis ma famille elle
chante super bien c'est la meilleure et
puis bah il y avait aussi ma fille qui
chantait donc pour moi c'est tout
bonheur j'ai pu la découvrir
différemment
et j'ai vu qu'elle était aussi bas
soutenu par tous les gens qui étaient là
et
[Musique]
le site créé en 1972 accueille
aujourd'hui environ 600 élèves répartis
entre la musique et le théâtre
[Musique]